afghanistan's government is saying
nothing this morning about the newest
victory by taliban fighters they've
captured a key city on a major
north-south highway and it's part of a
crushing week-long advance that's
happening while the u.s prepares to
withdraw the last of its troops by the
end of this month roxanna saberi is in
kabul for us that's afghanistan's
capital roxanna good morning to you as
we understand it the taliban are getting
ever closer to where you are right now
that's right tony a local official tells
us the taliban have taken the city of
ghazni today that city is only about 90
miles southwest of us here in the
capital kabul ghazni is the 10th
provincial capital to fall to the
taliban in only a week most have been in
the north but a few have been in the
south and west the insurgent's rapid
victories are cutting off cities under
government control and overwhelming
afghan forces today the u.s embassy said
the taliban could be committing war
crimes in the city of farah a video
appears to show the taliban dragging the
dead body of an afghan security force
member through the city shouting god is
great and elsewhere the taliban are
showing off humvees and weapons they've
seized from afghan forces the fighting
has forced hundreds of thousands of
people to flee in recent months many are
coming to kabul seeking safety they've
left behind their homes their belongings
and even loved ones killed in the
fighting and now they say there's
nowhere else to go
here in kabul life appears to be
carrying on more or less as usual but
for how long is unclear this would be
the biggest prize for the taliban and
according to a u.s military assessment
the city could fall could come under
attack in as little as 30 days data all
right roxanna siberia in afghanistan
thank you